it was a brutal loss she was the nicest
warmest most down-to-earth and even at
that moment when they were in their
peak of fame the first time i was on the
show
and she was the nicest you know warmest
person really a lovely girl gloria
estefan
opens up about the death of her glee
co-star
nya rivera i send a lot of prayers out
to that family
gloria played maribel lopez the mom of
nia's character
santana lopez on the hit musical comedy
this is your first moment of adulthood
memory from now on
it's up to you naya died in a boating
accident
on lake pairu in california in july
team jenna what are you doing here this
is like the ultimate bad luck god a
bride cannot see your bride before the
ceremony
of course fans of glee watched nya's
character fall in love and marry
brittany pierce
played by heather morris on the hit show
and the 62 year old singer explained
how playing santana's mama on screen
parallels her real-life
experience as a mom to her daughter
emily who is also a lesbian
we have had um a lot to deal with over
these past few months for sure we're all
still kind of reeling from
the news about naya rivera and i know
you played her mama on glee what's an
interesting thing too that i've thought
about later
i played her mother and she was
she came out in that show like their
character
and then me without even knowing
that that was going to be also me your
life
went down the line and i really got i
was happy that i was able to
put out the supportive mother you know
for her character on that show naya was
first reported missing after she took a
boat ride with her son
josie you love being a mommy oh my gosh
yes
authorities say her final moments were
likely spent saving the four-year-old's
life
there are a lot of currents on the lake
the idea perhaps being that the boat
started drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself gloria
says when she first heard the news that
naya was missing
she remained hopeful i was hoping
beyond hope because i'm a boater i've
been on a boat with my
small child and
i was you know hoping that maybe
she'd gotten him up on the boat and then
somehow been caught up in the current
and made it to shore and hadn't been
able
i was hoping i was inventing all these
scenarios that could have been
when i saw her mom kneeling by that lake
my heart just
ripped her shred because i know what she
had to be feeling and it's horrendous
and
you know we'll never know what actually
happened all i knew is that she did make
sure that her son
got to safety it was it was a brutal
loss and she was
you know we got to spend time with her
and emilio was
actually had been working on her after i
did the performance working with her
to get some music because she wanted to
do a recording then she got married and
had the baby
but she was the nicest you know warmest
person really a lovely girl but you're a
triple threat
such a loss